und
Leute wisst ihr eigentlich wie nice es ist eine Klimaanlage zu haben nicht im Sommer
zu kalt machen aber jetzt auch weil die meisten Klimaanlagen sind ja Kombi Geräte also die
können kühlen und wärmen und ich bin gerade hier oben ins Arbeitszimmer gekommen der ganze
Tag Tür offen gestanden der Flur ist jetzt nicht so sonderlich warm was irgendwie 20
Grad habe ich mir jetzt ein bisschen kalt hab ich die Heizung angemacht Heizung fängt
an ich damit bis das jetzt alles richtig warm ist also Klimaanlage an gedrückt eingestellt
24 Grad das Ding instant warme Luft raus und jetzt irgendwie 3-4 Minuten später das ganze
Zimmer warm es ist ohne Scheiß ist besser als Heizung es ist aber auch bestimmt teurer als
Heizung also für kurzzeitig war warm machen ist das wunderbar aber dauerhaft keine allzu gute
Idee aber so mal kurz 3-4 Minuten das ordentlich aufwärmen lassen ist toll also es hat sich gelohnt
Klimaanlage sowohl im Sommer als auch jetzt im Winter also komplett Pog ja ich weiß es ist 13
Uhr 12 da sind wahrscheinlich noch nicht so viele Leute da beziehungsweise viele Leute auf der
Arbeit aber was willst du machen es wird ernst Leute ich muss jetzt endlich mal mein Rechner
bestellen dass das im Dezember was wird moin Leute du hast Urlaub ja ich auch ich auch bis
3. Januar wie lange hast du Urlaub also ich muss 3. Januar wieder hin das ist ein Dienstag
muss gleich zum ersten Tag dann auch richtig schön wieder nach Frankfurt fahren du wartest
auf der neuen Server zu daheim wie war es in Würzburg schlechtes Wetter du musst am 5.
Setke 8 Dezember nicht Januar ja ich muss leider leider mit der ich muss glücklicherweise erst
im Januar wieder richtig setke und mal gucken wie lange noch ich habe jetzt noch eine Bewerbung
offen auf die warte ich auf jeden Fall noch weil wenn die klappen sollte als wenn der Laden taugt
das weiß ich noch nicht so genau ich hatte nicht so wirklich einen großartigen Eindruck von denen
ich hatte nur mal ganz kurz so vor vor gefühlt vor geredet aber großartige Vorstellungsrunde
hatte ich da noch nicht aber wenn das was wird dann werde ich auf jeden fall das machen und
nicht dass das andere einzig und allein wegen der Kohle ich gebe es zu ich bin bestechlich aber
auf fünf tage gerechnet 20.000 euro mehr im Jahr da werde ich nicht nein sagen also was
also auf fünf tage gerechnet sprich ihr könnt es mal mal 0,8 rechnen also bis in paar vier tagen
16 also bei 16 kam mehr im Jahr das sage ich nicht nein der Rest hat auch einen ganz guten
Eindruck gemacht sage ich nicht nein also mein jetziger Job und das wo ich mich also ich hatte
ja mehrere Bewerbungen die erste war ja schon vor ein paar Monaten die lief auch nicht schlecht
aber die haben es ja dann dazu entschieden sie wollen wegen finanziellen sachen dieses
Jahr keine neuen Leute einstellen dann war das jetzt wo ich auch in Würzburg gewesen bin das
lief eigentlich auch ganz gut das ist so ungefähr das gleiche was ich jetzt verdiene so ungefähr so
ganz grob aber das andere wo ich mich noch beworben habe ist halt so ein ding wenn das klappt und wenn
der Laden traugt wie gesagt wie das von außen aussieht und was man so für den ersten Eindruck
hat natürlich ist ja nicht verkehrt aber dann muss ich das natürlich mal angucken also wenn
der Laden taugt und wenn er stimmt was sie gesagt haben von wegen 90k 90 bis 100k also das war eine
der wenigen die ich gesehen habe die in ihre stellenausschreibung tatsächlich schon ein
Gehalt reingeschrieben haben was auch der einzige Grund war warum ich mich da beworben habe muss ich
euch ehrlich sagen der Rest klingt auch gar nicht so schlecht aber wegen dem Rest hätte ich mich
da nicht beworben ich habe mich einzeln allein dort beworben weil die 90 bis 100k geschrieben
haben auf fünf Tage gerechnet wohl ja und ganz ehrlich sollten die so halbwegs sollte das so
halbwegs taugen unter stimmt was sie da reingeschrieben haben dann mache ich das weil
ich bin insofern schon bestechlich also arbeitsbedingungen alles schön und gut sage
ich nichts dagegen und mir hat es auch wirklich gut gefallen dort in würzburg bei denen man war
auch mit den leuten so auf einer wellenlänge und so alles kein ding aber das ist halt schon mal
eine hausnummer ja da bin ich bestechlich was das angeht also ist es halt weil wir arbeiten
alle nicht just for fun es sollte natürlich nicht komplett der abfang sein da sind wir uns
glaube ich einig aber unterm strich aber in wir alle weil wir geld dafür kriegen und klar man
kann das mit arbeitsbedingungen coole atmosphäre dass es irgendwie ein super laden ist was auch
immer man kann das alles bis zum gewissen grad schon aufwiegen oder auch was nahverkehr anbindung
angeht und sonst was in der richtung aber unterm strich wenn die andere seite so viel mehr kohle
bezahlt da kann es nichts machen da bin ich bestechlich tatsächlich was für ein unterschied
das macht ja wie gesagt ungefähr 20k auf fünf tage gerechnet
ja das wollen sie auch jetzt ist ja noch besser leute der grund warum ich mich dort beworben
habe ist weil sie erst also erstens passt das von von von der stellenbeschreibung ja
ganz okay ja aber ich habe mich dort nur beworben weil da steht 100 prozent remold 90 bis 100 k
im jahr habe ich weiß was probierste einfach mal aus und wenn das was wird dann bin ich echt
bestechlich weil home office ist ja der hauptgrund warum ich dort weg will wo ich aktuell bin gar
nicht so sehr die kohle sondern hauptsächlich hauptsächlich die die home office geschichte
das wiegt für mich auch ein bisschen zunut ein bisschen geld auf aber ansonsten ich bin
bestechlich was das angeht für das klo review hast du dir auch eins gekauft du hast hier
bestimmt ein nachfolger gekauft oder falls du dir eins gekauft hast weil das was ich hab gibt
es ja gar nicht mehr es gibt jetzt nachfolger ich glaube die neuen ach du hast den aufsatz
gekauft die neuen aufsätze die haben doch mittlerweile glaube ich sogar touchscreens
oder habe ich da nicht letztendlich was gesehen haben die neuen nicht sogar touch touchpads
mehr la weile
Also die sollten eigentlich die Sachen von einer eigenen Domain ausliefern.
Gut, ich meine Kompetenz im Klo-Design heißt ja nicht automatisch Kompetenz im Webdesign.
Ach, die Seiten gehen, okay.
Die haben kein LCD.
Ich hab letztens mal ein Bild gesehen, ich weiß aber nicht ob's Geberit ist.
Die hatten tatsächlich LCD, oder ich weiß nicht ob's ein Touchscreen oder nur ein LCD-Display war.
LCD-Display am Klo, aber die sind's anscheinend.
Ach, sowas hast du dir gekauft, so ein Aufsatz.
Die sind's anscheinend nicht.
Na gut.
Ach, du hast dir eins aus China bestellt.
Ja, ist bestimmt eine ganze Ecke billiger.
Ja, ungewöhnlicher Zeitpunkt, aber es wird jetzt mal Zeit mit Rechner bestellen.
Wir labern heute, ob's falsche Seite, wir labern heute auch nicht lange rum.
Muss mal kurz ein neues Fenster aufmachen.
Geilzeit, heute geht's zur Sache Leute.
Heute wird, sag ich mal, 80-90% muss fertig werden, was denn da eingebaut wird,
dass ich den Kram schon mal bestellen kann.
Also Sachen, die nicht unbedingt 100%ig klar sein müssen, ist so,
welcher Ram es exakt wird, weil Ram gibt es aktuell wie Sand am Meer überall zu kaufen, das ist kein Ding.
Also ob, wie gesagt, ob ich jetzt 5600 DDR5 nehme, 6000, 6000, was auch immer,
das ist nicht so wild, ja, da klick ich noch raus, oder ob ich jetzt ne
Samsung 970 Evo oder ne 980 Pro oder sowas,
das ist nicht so wild, ich werd da jetzt was reinpacken, aber das ist nicht so wild.
Wichtig ist, ähm, CPU, Mainboard,
wobei selbst Mainboard gar nicht mal 100%ig festgelegt werden muss,
aber als Base brauch ich das, weil ich muss ja irgendwo draufstecken.
CPU, Mainboard, also CPU weiß ich eh schon, DDR5 wird's auf jeden Fall, ja.
CPU ist 13900K.
Ich weiß, dass das für relativ wenig Sinn macht, gerade für hauptsächlich in Gaming Content,
aber ich will's haben, das ist das, was überwiegt.
Ähm, 4090, da bin ich mir auch noch nicht ganz exakt so sicher, welche genau,
da müssen wir gleich mal gucken, das ist mit der Musiklos viel zu laut.
Dankeschön für den Sub, Möb.
Warum nicht KF?
Weil der KF teurer aktuell ist und ich so ne Onboard-GPU gar nicht verkehrt finde.
Da kann man das Ding auch mal einschalten und gucken, ob alles geht,
soll es irgendwie Probleme machen, schadet nix.
Macht auch nicht wirklich was aus, was bei Temperaturen und Verbrauch anbelangt.
Eigentlich nennenswert.
So, und das Wichtigste ist, wo wir uns jetzt tatsächlich drauf festlegen müssen,
was es für eine Kombination aus Kühlung, Gehäuse und CPU gibt.
Ich tendiere aktuell, wie gesagt, 13900K,
ähm, ne Wasserkühlung und ne Gehäuse, wo das reinpasst.
Ich tendiere aktuell zu irgendeiner Arctic Cooling Freezer, genau, zu so nem Teil.
Vielleicht sogar die 420, vielleicht, vielleicht sogar die Arctic Freezer 420.
Die ist halt besonders fett, die hat drei Lüfter mit 120, nee, 140 Millimeter.
Corsair 5000 Airflow, naja, Airflow mit ner Wasserkühlung ist erstmal nicht so wild, oder?
Also ich mein, klar, für Grafikkarte, Spannungsbande und sonst wie,
aber so ein bisschen Zug durchs Gehäuse kriegst du ja mit allem hin.
Und, und ne weitere, ne weitere Frage ist, ähm,
ich hab noch gar nix großartig ausgewählt, ich erzähl das, was mir so grad im Kopf rumschwebt,
ich hab noch nix angeklickt dafür.
Ja, und, und die abschließende Frage ist, lass ichs mir zusammenbauen oder nicht?
Können wir, können wir theoretisch machen.
Aber ich mach hier ne Geizhalzliste und das können wir auch hier drüber machen.
Kann man das auf Euro stellen?
Germany?
Hab ich glaub ich noch nie benutzt.
Das ist halt die Frage, lass ichs mir zusammenbauen, machst du die Liste öffentlich?
Ja, aber erst nachdem ich bestellt hab.
So ich weiß es noch, ich hab letztens, letztens, letztens ist es gut, vor 5 Jahren hab ich die
Geizhalzliste gepostet und danach gab's keine CPUs mehr zu kaufen.
Also bisschen Einfluss scheint es schon darauf gehabt zu haben.
Ähm, ja, also das ist halt die Frage, normalerweise, normalerweise wollte ich selbst zusammenbauen
und das ist ja auch nicht schwierig in der heutigen Zeit PCs zusammenzubauen, muss man
auch mal sagen.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, an Zeiten früher, da konntest du tatsächlich
noch irgendwie Sachen falsch stöpseln, wenn du nicht aufgepasst hast, ja, gerade wenn
du irgendwelche IDE-Kabel hattest ohne Nase dran, links rum, rechts rum, wie auch immer
funktioniert das Ganze, gut, meistens ist nix rapport gegangen bei, aber du konntest
zumindest noch Sachen falsch stöpseln und heute kannst du ja eigentlich nichts mehr
falsch stöpseln.
Was kannst du bei nem Rechner heutzutage falsch stecken?
Du kannst den RAM nicht falsch rein machen, du kannst die Stecker alle nicht falsch rein
machen, was, was kannst du heute noch großartig falsch machen beim Rechnerbauen?
Du kannst zerstören, wenn du es reindrückst, wo es nicht rein soll, ja, Front-Io, den Müll
kannst du immer noch falsch stecken, ja, was mit denen, was mit denen los ist, weiß ich
auch nicht.
Die, die USB-Onboard-Dinger kannst du auch nicht falsch machen.
Da bin ich am überlegen, ob ich nicht in Netz teilnehme, da gibt's ja mittlerweile
welche, ob ich nicht in Netz teilnehme, das schon ATX3-Anschlüsse hat, könnte man sich
mal überlegen.
Das passiert auch bei den ATX3-Netzteilen, ja genau, ja gut, aber nur, wenn du nicht
richtig, richtig reingesteckt hast, bei den anderen gab's ja wohl auch Probleme, wenn's
abgeknickt war.
ATX3, das ist ein neuer Standard für Mainboards und Netzteile, hauptsächlich Netzteile, das
ist dann quasi, die haben dann PCI-Express-5-Stecker, Abstandhalter nicht nutzen, welche Abstandhalter?
Nee, RGB gibt's nicht, ich werd den komplett RGB-los bauen.
RGB-los, ja.
Ich bau auch ohne Fenster, ohne Fenster, okay, fangen wir mal an.
Was, was nehmen wir, dann nehmen wir jetzt den PC-Part-Picker.
Das Ding hab ich noch nie verwendet, ich hätt jetzt einfach ne Geizhalsliste gemacht.
Was kann denn der PC-Part-Picker?
Ich mach Geizhals.
Um Kompatibilität zu checken, ja das können wir am Ende, das können wir am Ende noch
machen.
Gucken wir doch mal, gucken wir mal, ob der das checkt.
Okay, das testen wir jetzt mal.
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt nen CPU-Kühler und dann nehmen wir jetzt Arctic Liquid Freezer
420 ohne RGB, so, add und dann gucken wir mal welches Case, Case, also empfehlen die
jetzt, zeigen die einem nur Cases, wo das reinpasst, siehste, das stimmt schon mal gar
nicht, in das Meshify 2 passt er nämlich nicht rein, der passt, der passt nur in das Meshify
2 XL rein.
Mal gucken, ob das Ding das checkt.
Alter, was ist Alter, nö, das juckt dir nicht, Keg-Wade, siehste, oh Nodes, ja, ne,
steht nicht da, siehste, funktioniert nicht, das hab ich nämlich vorher extra irgendwo
nachgeguckt, dass das Meshify 2 ist zu klein, man braucht das Meshify XL, wir machen, wir
machen ne Geizhalsliste, Wunschlisten, das NAS, ne, das brauchen wir nicht, Wunschliste
erstellen, Omega-Lull.
Wäre schon ein bescheuerter Name, ne, ne, ne, ne, da steht nicht, dass sie nicht passen,
da steht, dass sie nicht gecheckt werden und da geht es nur um RAM und CPU-Kühler-Abstand,
also das sagt nichts dazu, dass es nicht zusammenpasst, aber ich hab's vorher nachgeguckt, ich
weiß, dass es nicht zusammenpasst, theoretisch würde es ganz knapp passen von den Abmaßen,
aber der hier ist zu dick, der ist zu pepo-fett, also Gehäuse hab ich schonmal geguckt, wahrscheinlich
wird's das hier, wahrscheinlich wird's das Gehäuse, Meshify 2 XL und zwar ohne Fenster,
so wie es hier ist, der Liquid Freezer ist pepo-fett, ja richtig fett, das ist ein schönes
Massive fettes XL, passt gut zu mir, Gehäuse, ist natürlich relativ teuer, aber das macht
es bei diesem Bild auch nicht mehr wirklich aus, be quiet hat bessere Gehäuse, ok, was
verstehst du unter besser, was würde mich jetzt interessieren, was ist besser, würdest
du sagen ein Ryzen 7800X 3D lohnt sich zum zocken, also wenn du wirklich ernsthaft spielen
willst, halte ich nix von Kombi sagen, ich mein, die letzte Konsolengeneration hatte
auch eine CPU-GPU-Kombi, aber das muss nicht sein, nee, also ganz ehrlich, wenn du was
spielen willst, würd ich mir immer ne CPU und ne ordentliche Grafikanne kaufen, ich
mein, es sei denn du spielst halt wirklich nur irgendwelche super anspruchslosen Games,
also CSGO zum Beispiel, ja, also ich muss sagen, du musst mich schon wirklich, du musst
mich schon wirklich überzeugen, warum die be quiet Gehäuse besser sind, ich hatte die
letzten vier PC-Generationen nur Fractal Design Gehäuse und ich schwör da drauf, also du
musst mich jetzt wirklich überzeugen, Taze, was an dem und vor allem welches be quiet
Gehäuse besser ist, aber ich dachte, das ist so ne Kombi, so ein Kombi-Gerät, so ne APU
oder sowas, was ist 3D-Cache, was es nicht alles gibt, 3D-Cache, nur für High IQ Benutzer,
ja, zum Spielen reicht das bestimmt, es reicht fast alles Aktuelles, was es zu kaufen gibt
an CPUs fürs Spielen, ok, also wir packen das jetzt rein, Wunschliste, es ist halt schon
nicht billig, muss man sagen, ja, so, nicht mit Glasfenster, ohne Glasfenster, im Moment
ist halt alles Glasfenster, gibt es nicht einfach ohne Glasfenster, ne, das ist ohne
Glasfenster, oder, ne, was auch immer, mich juckt es nicht, ob es ein Glasfenster hat oder
nicht, aber ich brauch ehrlich gesagt, ach Dark Tint ist das, dunkles Glasfenster, ja
ok, kann ich auch mitleben, ok, also, wo geht das jetzt, hier, Wunschliste hinzufügen,
zu Omega Lul, sehr schön, NEXT, ach, das ist die kommende Generation, oder was, für
einen anderen, ne, ne, die ist schon, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, nööhööö jersey
bro mystery.
Ok, was ist euer Vorschlag Chat Li
Das ist fett, ja das Meshify XL ist auch fett.
Yep, RGB, ne ne ne ne ne, das bleibt das hier.
Ich mein guck mal, was sind denn die Abmaße hier?
Abmaße?
Hier, äh, hier Abmessung und was hat das andere?
Abmessung.
Wo ist es denn jetzt, oh das ist unnötig hier, aber das ist ja nochmal fetter mann.
Ok, ok, das ist breiter, das eine ist breiter, aber das hier ist ein Stück ein Ticken höher
und länger.
Ah ja, was meinste, was meinste, ne das passt schon, das Gehäuse, also wie gesagt, ich
mag Fractal Design, wir müssen bloß grad mal gucken wo das Netzteil hinkommt bei dem
Case.
Ich mag Fractal Design, ich hatte die letzten vier Konsolen, äh nicht Konsolen, vier PC
Generationen von denen und da muss schon, ah unten kommt das hin.
Ja gut, das ist ja ok, unten hab ich ja genug Platz.
Oben kommt der Radiator rein, unten kommt das Netzteil rein, dann hab ich aus irgendwelchen
Gründen hier neben noch, äh, drei hochkante Slots, wofür sind denn die da, wofür sind
hochkante Slots da, hä, was denn das?
Fractaler GPU Mount, sowas gibt's?
Warum macht man das?
Ach, falls man CPU, falls man die auch Wasser kühlen will und Platz braucht oder wie ist
das?
Oder hab ich, hab ich noch nie angeguckt, kein Plan.
Nur Optik, ok.
Du würdest dir das nicht nochmal kaufen, warum, weil es dir zu groß ist, warum nicht?
Weil es dir zu groß ist oder was halt, würdest du es nicht mehr kaufen?
Ich brauch halt ein großes Gehäuse, dass ich die Kühlung reinkrieg.
Jetzt mal ne blöde Frage, wenn ich da ne Wasser, zu offen, Akustik, achso, ja das ist
ok.
Wenn ich da ne Wasserkühlung reinbaue, was die hier auch haben, denk ich mal, oder?
Ja.
Müsste das da nicht offen, müsste das nicht oben?
Ach das, achso, ok, das ist oben, zum Luft ansaugen, passt schon, alles klar, beziehungsweise
zum luftlos werden auch, ja.
Äh, das ist ok.
Schön überall Staubfilter, das ist top.
Es kommen, ah, es kommen zwei Lüfter mit, ein Lüfter, zwei Lüfter für vorne, einer
für hinten, das ist eigentlich genau die richtige Kombi.
Was kostet der Gerät, 220 Euro oder sowas.
Gute Kombination, zwei Lüfter vorne, ein Lüfter hinten, man sollte ja immer gucken,
dass ein bisschen Überdruck im Rechner ist, das hat den Vorteil, dass weniger Staub reinkommt.
So, wunderbar, sehr schön, next, Arctic Freezer, ne, nicht Arctical, Alter, 420, nicht RGB,
ohne RGB, haben wir nicht, sowas da, genau, das Teil.
Ich hab mir einige Tests angeguckt, das Ding ist richtig fett, von den Abmaßen her, aber
die CPU braucht auch ordentlich fette Kühlung, im Gamingbetrieb weniger, aber wenn ich mal
Videos rende oder wenn ich einfach mal Just For Fun Rubbel Benchmark Ergebnisse haben
will, dann braucht die das, das Ding kann gut mit dem NHD, Leute, ich lobe Noctua ja auch
immer und die Noctua Lüfter sind gut, aber in einer ordentlichen Wasserkühlung, wenn
man sich Tests anguckt, kann nichts anstinken dagegen.
Wenn das so einfach wäre, dann würde ich mir mit der Luftkühlung eine Noctua einbauen.
Zwei Lüfter blasen rein und zwei raus, ne, es blasen zwei rein und einer raus, ach ne,
du meinst, du meinst mit der Wasserkühlung oben drinnen noch, ja das stimmt, das stimmt
wohl, ne, der NH15 ist gar, also der, der mag vielleicht mithalten mit den kleinen 240
oder was es ist, Wasserkühlung, aber mit den großen auf gar keinen Fall, weil für
die meisten CPUs ist das egal, aber gerade die neuen, die ziehen ordentlich und werden
wahnsinnig warm.
Es sind sogar fünf raus, stimmt, man hat ja noch Grafikkarte, Netzteil, ne, das ist trotzdem
nicht verkehrt.
Da muss ich ja hinten, den muss ich ja nicht einschalten, ah, das wird schon gehen, ne,
das wird schon gehen.
So, also, wo sind wir, alle Varianten ist das Teufel überhaupt lieferbar, ja, ist es, hinzufügen,
zur Wunschliste hinzufügen, Omega Lul, du findest Wasserkühlung bei aktuellen CPUs
unsinnig, da kann man sich jetzt, da kann man sich eigentlich fast schon nicht mehr drüber
streiten, wenn man sich anguckt, was die aktuellen Dinger für Leistung verbraten beziehungsweise
wie heiß die werden.
Lass Wunschliste, oh, hab ich sie in die falsche gepackt, ne, oder, ne, ne, passt, passt, so,
also weiter, CPU, die CPU können wir reinmachen, das ist relativ einfach, ohne Kühler, ja,
was ist denn der Vorteil noch von Boxed, wenn da kein Lüfter dabei ist, mehr Garantie oder,
nein, warum nimmst du Intel, weil Intel aktuell was Gaming angeht, die etwas bessere, natürlich
kommt es immer ein bisschen auf die Games an, aber im Durchschnitt ist Intel was Games
angeht zur Zeit besser.
Vor zwei Monaten oder so habe ich tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich mir endlich mal ein AMD
System zusammenbaue, weil es wurde mal wieder Zeit für neuen Rechner, ich dachte mir, ey,
wartest du bis AMD die neuen Dinger vorstellt, und ich war kurz davor, wir hatten sogar schon
mal zusammengeklickt im Stream, kurz davor, aber dann kam Intel um die Ecke und hat gesagt
nope, nimm eine All-in-one, wovon Werk nachfüllbar ist, ich kaufe mir eine All-in-one, weil ich
daran nichts nachfüllen will, weil das einmal noch gut ist, aber die haben mittlerweile
glaube ich sogar 8 Jahre Garantie drauf, also bisschen getestet müssen sie den Kram haben,
vertausche ich ihm, ganz ehrlich, die Wasserkühlung kostet 120 Euro, sollte mir das Ding verrecken,
soll sie mir eine neue schicken, und ansonsten kaufe ich mir eine neue, wurscht.
So, dann fügen wir das mal hinzu, zur Wunschliste hinzufügen Omega Lul, wir machen mal die Omega
Lul Wunschliste auf, dass ich den Überblick behalte, gut, das war jetzt noch das einfache,
CPU, Gehäuse, Kühler, ja ich frag mich auch wo das hin verdunsten soll, durch den Schlauch,
hast du die CPU vorzuköpfen, nein, hab ich nicht, ich hab mein 8700K geköpft, aber da
war ja noch Wärmeleitpaste zwischen Heatspreader und Oberseite von der CPU, das mach ich beim
neuen nicht, das bleibt so wie es ist, brauchst du ein Laptop zum Programmieren, bin unschlüssig,
ich habe keine Ahnung, ich hab schon ewig kein Notebook mehr gekauft, kann ich dir nichts
zu sagen, so, jetzt wirds aber komplizierter, ich mach mal die Sachen rein, die einfach
sind noch, die Sachen die einfach sind, ich mach beispielsweise mal eine SSD rein, das
ist noch easy, da eine SSD auszusuchen, also was nehmen wir denn, Samsung, da hab ich eigentlich
immer ganz gute Erfahrungen gemacht, es soll NVMe sein, ja und mindestens, mindestens
2TB, was haben wir da zu bieten, Reis pro Terabyte, ja alles klar, Kek, und am besten,
am besten noch lieferbar, 970 EVO, 980 pro, 2TB, was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem
und dem, ach Moment, das ist nur der Kühlkörper, ne das ist die SSD mit Kühlkörper, aber ich
brauch keinen Kühlkörper, weil die meisten Mainboards haben auch mittlerweile Kühlkörper,
ok was sagt der Chat, lieber eine was, ist das WD vom Namen her, ne Seagate, 500 wenn
der Chat das sagt, und warum ist die besser, preislich nimmt sich das jetzt eigentlich
dann wirklich was, und auch von den Werten entnimmt sich das dann wirklich was, echt
kein großer Unterschied, was ich pack da jetzt das Samsung Ding rein und gut is, fertig aus,
zur Wunschliste hinzufügen, Omega Lull, so das ist noch wie gesagt, das ist noch die
einfache Variante, und wir sind schon, wir sind schon, wir sind schon ohne Grafik, wir
haben schon ein paar tausend 300 Euro, da kommt nochmal locker 2000, 200 Euro drauf,
Samsung für die Grafikkarte dann, ok was haben wir noch, was ist auch noch, was ist
auch noch easy, was ist auch noch easy, also RAM, RAM könnten wir schon mal gucken, oder
Netzteil, ok wir gucken RAM und Netzteil, wobei das alles auch ein bisschen vom Mainboard
abhängt, aber Mainboard wird ein bisschen komplizierter, RAM, Netzteil, Netzteil, wir
gucken mal kurz Netzteil, weil ich will mal gucken, wie viele ATX3 Netzteile es überhaupt
gibt, Netzteile, die SSD mit Kühlkörper, ja wenn das aber die 5 Euro, macht jetzt nichts,
also Netzteile, brauchst du wirklich ein 13900, ja brauche ich unbedingt, wäre ein 13700
wahrscheinlich ausreichend, ja wäre ausreichend, das ist korrekt, wahrscheinlich wäre auch
ein 13600 ausreichend, also wenn es nach ausreichend geht, müsste ich mir wahrscheinlich gar keinen
neuen Rechner kaufen, rein wenn es um ausreichend geht, wie lief das Vorstellungsgespräch nicht
schlecht, nee das ist billig Zeug, das will ich nicht, ATX3, aha da kann man sortieren,
POG, was haben wir hier, MSI, ich meine ich vermeide ja MSI eigentlich zu kaufen, und
ihr wisst genau warum ich das vermeide, aber wenn ich mir das hier so angucke, macht es
einen ganz guten Eindruck auf den ersten Blick, be quiet hat anscheinend noch keine ATX3 Netzteile,
also ich kaufe ungern MSI, weil die mich aus irgendwelchen Gründen auf Twitter gebannt
haben, und ich bis heute nicht weiß warum, so also lass mal kurz gucken, was haben wir
da, also Stuff Gaming, das klingt schon wieder, na 850 ist eigentlich in Ordnung, aber be quiet
hat ein direktes Netzteil zu 12 Volt Powerkabel, ah das ist gut, ich dachte das haben nur die
ATX3 Netzteile, welches be quiet hat denn das neue Netzteil, also welches be quiet Netzteil
hat denn das neue, 12 oder 16 Pin oder wie viel Pin Kabel das ist, 16 Pin Kabel ist das
oder, jetzt zeig mal her, be quiet introduces 12 Volt HPWR Adapter, wer hat diese Abkürzung
wieder ausgedacht man, 12 Volt kann ich ja noch verstehen und was ist das, der P ist
PCI Express Power, nee Power, Power, was ist H, High Power, 12 Volt High Power Adapter,
Five Hat Abkürzung, what the fuck, ein Zipp, ein fucking Zipp, ich lad doch keine Zips
runter hier, Adapter Kabel, na ja Adapter Kabel ist doch sogar bei der Grafikkarte dabei
oder, also ich mein, wo ist denn da noch der, wo ist denn da jetzt der, ach nee das ist
so ein Kabel, was ich direkt ans Netzteil klippen kann, das ist das was man direkt ins
Netzteil klippen kann, also im Prinzip braucht man dann gar kein ATX3 Netzteil, 20 Euro,
ich hoffe es ist ein komischer Adapter, was ist denn zum Beispiel mit dem Ding hier, gibt
es zu diesem Ding, gibt es da irgendwelche, gibt es da irgendwelche, gibt es irgendwelche
Reviews so, Asus Rock Strix, die haben immer Namen bei Asus, aha, anders funktioniert
ein Modulares ATX3 Netzteil, das stimmt, außer dass sie ansonsten ATX3 Specs erfüllen müssen,
1000 Watt mein ich, na ja warum nicht, habt recht, warum eigentlich nicht, was ist mit
dem hier, taugt das, Review, ok Zeitmeier, schlechte Rear, warum, Cons, not competitive
overall, Performance, das ist schlecht, low efficiency under light and super light loads,
not so quiet, ok das ist Mist, ja dann kann ich mal auch, hat Seasonic auch so einen Adapter,
wie heißt dieses Ding, 12 Volt H, oder könnte ich vielleicht einfach das nehmen, nee ich
hab kein 1000 Watt Netzteil da, ich mein die haben auch so ein Ding, ja, ich weiß nicht,
ich schmeiß da jetzt einfach mal irgendein x-beliebiges Netzteil rein mit 1000 Watt,
Gucken wir mal, Leistung, was haben wir denn hier schönes, Kohling, Mars Gaming, ok, warte
mal, lass mal ein paar Hersteller nehmen, die mir was sagen, einmal be quiet, oder vergangen
fand ich die eigentlich immer ganz nice, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten, ok das sieht
billig aus, be quiet, Pure Power 11, das glaube ich so der Klassiker, nee, nee, Straight Power
11, das glaube ich so der Klassiker, das hat glaube ich jeder zweite bei sich im Rechner,
oder, dieses Teil, ich glaube das dürfte eines der meist verbauten Netzteile überhaupt sein,
wie schauts damit aus, ist da auch irgendwas Platinum Rated, ah nee die hier, ok, es lohnt
sich eigentlich gar nicht so sehr dafür Geld auszugeben, wisst ihr was, ich packe jetzt
einfach mal das da rein, das da oder das da, macht preislich eigentlich die 3 Euro, kommt
immer das, ich packe das jetzt einfach mal da rein, Netzteil kann man ja noch gucken,
zur Wunschliste hinzufügen, omega lul, alles klar, so jetzt wirds spannend, jetzt brauchen
wir nämlich ein Mainboard, oder gibts doch irgendwas was ich reinpacken kann was auch
noch easy ist, Netzteil, Lüftergehäuse, RAM, SSD, also außer RAM haben wir alles, also
außer RAM und Netzteil, CD Laufwerke, alles klar, ok Arbeitsspeicher, so wir wollen DDR5
und wir wollen 5600 mindestens, Raid Controller Karte, nee sowas brauch ich da drinnen nicht,
wozu, wozu brauch ich ne Raid Karte, da kommt ne SSD dran, da kommt ne NVMe SSD dran und
ne 10TB Platte die ich hier rumliegen hab, fertig.
Es wird kein PC, es wird ziemlich teuer werden, ok Leute 5600 vs 6400, mal gucken was der
preislich der Unterschied ist, ups, lul, lass mal kurz gucken was der preislich der Unterschied
ist, ok lass mal kurz schauen, was haben wir denn hier, Preis pro Gigabyte, Team Elite,
nee Team Group Elite, so noch nie gehört man, also aktuell hab ich Gskill Trident oder
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung als RAM, sowas so, irgendwas in der Richtung hab ich
aktuell als RAM, ok 64Gig, 64Gig, 36, also CL36 glaube ich relativ gut, guck mal was,
das nimmt sich alles in dem Bereich jetzt nicht so wirklich viel, mach so 128, nee 64G
reicht, 64G reicht, ok ich will das mal vergleichen kurz, also, was ist der Preis, warum gibt's
das so, und das übertrieben viel, ok also wir sind ungefähr bei 5,6 pro Gigabyte, bei
5600, so und was kostet da, ok da kostet 2 Euro mehr, 2-3 Euro mehr, was ist denn das
letzte hier hinten, 32,39,39, warum ist das hier billiger als das, das ist doch langsamer,
das ist doch langsamer, aber es ist teurer, muss ich das jetzt verstehen, nee RGB haben
sie beide, ach nee das ist 6600, nee nee wir machen mal genau 6400, weil ansonsten
ist das nicht wirklich vergleichbar, also hier bezahle ich für den RAM, hier bezahle
ich für 64G ungefähr 360 Euro und hier würde ich dann für 64G, oh das ist schon ein Unterschied,
das ist tatsächlich ein Unterschied, komm mal 64G 359 und hier bezahle ich für 64G,
nehmen wir das einfach mal 2, 500 Euro, macht schon einen Unterschied, ich mein bei dem
Gesamtpreis macht es jetzt nicht wirklich die Sache fett, muss man auch mal sagen, man
muss auch ehrlich sagen 32GB würde auch reichen, aber ihr kennt mich, mein neues System muss
mindestens in allen Bereichen so gut sein wie das aktuelle, eigentlich immer besser.
Das läppert sich, ja da wird sich ein paar hundert Euro am Ende machen, wtf warum ist
das so langsam, das ist ohne RGB, deswegen ist es so billig, ach das hat ECC, haben die
nicht alle ECC, doch ganz ehrlich sind doch alle ECC oder, also ganz im Ernst, die Dinger
sind alle ungefähr gleich schnell, sowohl von den Timings als auch von der Taktrate,
nimmt sich eigentlich, außer die hier die langsamer sind aber mehr kosten, nimmt sich
eigentlich gar nichts großartig, warum dann nicht einfach das billigste nehmen, was kein
RGB hat, weil ich will eh kein RGB, was bedeutet CL23, das hat irgendwas mit Zugriffszeiten
beim RAM zu tun, ich kann ja gar nicht genau sagen aus dem Kopf, welche Timings jetzt
für was das ist, Row Axis, Column Axis und das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, ich nehme
einfach das Ding hier um ohne RGB, mein Scheiß drauf, ich brauch kein RGB, 32G, ja zack,
das ganze halt nochmal 2 dann am Ende, zur Wunschliste hinzufügen, Omega Lul, jetzt
müssen wir mal zur Wunschliste und müssen da noch eintragen, dass es 2 mal das RAM
gibt, mal 2, oh das wird sehr günstig, da kommt jetzt noch die Grafikkarte dabei Leute,
das wird ein Schnapper und das war es noch nicht, wisst ihr was das Schlimme ist, dass
da ja noch mehr dabei kommt, ich mein, ich brauch noch ein neues Handy dieses Jahr, ich
will mir einen neuen OLED Monitor kaufen, neue Capture Card, ich hab mir erst ein Auto gekauft
und ein Mainboard kommt auch noch dabei, ja, das wird teurer, Dezember, Omg, aber irgendjemand
muss ja was für die Wirtschaft in Deutschland tun, ne, Autoreview, stimmt, ich wollte euch
ja in einem Video mein Auto zeigen, mein Fiat, ok Mainboard, jetzt wird es kompliziert, Mainboard,
also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall schon mal Sockel, wo ist er, da und wir brauchen Z790,
ich weiß, dass man theoretisch auch Z690 nehmen kann, aber wenn schon dann das neue, so, dann
brauchen wir noch ein paar andere Sachen, auf die ich Wert lege, nämlich es braucht mindestens
einen optischen Audio Ausgang und er braucht RAM-Takt mindestens 6400, Takt, ach ne, RAM-Takt,
Max, ne, das ist ok, das packen wir alle und 5 und DDR5 natürlich RAM, DDR5 RAM, viermal,
genau, so viele Mainboard gibt es jetzt nämlich schon gar nicht mehr zur Auswahl, guckt mal,
hältst du in Grenzen, das ist alles, was es gibt und ich gebe, ha, null, wobei ganz ehrlich
zweimal RAM ist auch ok, zweimal RAM ist auch ok, was habe ich denn hier ausgewählt, Omega
null, ah, sind das schon zwei, was ist besser, Leute, gibt es irgendeinen theoretischen Vorteil
von vier Riegel versus zwei Riegel, weil das macht preislich keinen großen Unterschied
dann, sieht cooler aus, wobei, guck mal, mit zwei gibt es gar nicht viel, mit zwei gibt
es nur drei Mainboards, null, ETX, ich glaube so ein kleines Mainboard ist nicht so sinnig
dafür, ich denke, ganz davon abgesehen Leute, wenn man vier Slots hat, kann man doch einfach
nur zwei Riegel rein machen, gell, das ist auch egal, das ist wahrscheinlich die bessere
Variante, zehn Gig, nee, zehn Gig Karten sind auf Mainboards zu teuer, ich mache da
ein paar PCI Express was rein, kaufe, ok, was haben wir hier, was sagt Alternate, Asus,
nee, nicht Alternate, Asus Promotion, bis zu 375 Euro Cashback oder Gutschein, kaufe
teilnehmende Asus Gaming Produkte und erhaltet bis zu 375 Cashback oder ein Gamingsplanet,
Gutschein, ok, was muss ich kaufen, Mainboards, Rock, Moment, ist da die 790 Keine dabei,
doch, achso, ja geil, da muss ich ein 600 Euro Mainboard kaufen und kriege dann 60 Euro
wieder und das eine kostet mich nur 350 oder sowas, ok, Grafikkarte, nee, GPUs sind hier
gar nicht drinne, oder, ok, also im Prinzip, wenn man den Asus Mainboard kauft, kriegt
man, kriegt man theoretisch ein bisschen Geld zurück, naja, ob sich das so lohnt, müssen
wir mal schauen, das müssen wir mal gucken, müssen wir mal schauen, lassen wir mal, gucken
wir mal, ob wir, guck mal, die sind viel zu teuer, die 10G Mainboards, null, guck mal,
ich gebe doch keine 646 Euro oder 1200 Euro für den Mainboard aus, guck mal, da bringt
es mir die 150 Euro Cashback bei Asus jetzt auch nicht, da kommt einfach eine PCI Express
rein für 10 Gig und fertig ist, die kostet, die kostet 30 Euro auf Ebay, wenn man sich
eine kaufen will, also der Aufpreis ist es wirklich net wert, vielleicht 2,5, vielleicht
2,5 onboard, konnten wir mal gucken, aber ich glaube die meisten etwas besseren haben 2,5
Gig mittlerweile, ist das ein Overclocking Mainboard, ein bisschen übertacken kannst
du die ganzen Premium Mainboards alle, aber die Mainboards sind mittlerweile bescheuert
teuer, ok, guck mal Leute, es gibt bloß 13 oder wie viele waren zur Auswahl jetzt, 26,
eben hatten wir doch nur noch 13 zur Auswahl, ach nee, da hatte ich noch DDR5 ausgewählt
hier, also DDR sind nur 17, nur 17 Mainboards zur Auswahl, also ganz ehrlich, die oberen
fallen eh raus, wir vergleichen das jetzt einfach mal, gucken uns das mal an, ja wunderbar,
die unteren jucken mich eh nicht, weil die viel zu teuer sind, ich meine, wie viel Cashback
kriege ich für dieses Ding, nix, Tricks, da, 80 Euro, das lohnt sich auch mit 80 Euro
nicht, guck mal da kriegste 80 Euro wieder, dann bezahlste 560 Euro, nee, 540 Euro und
dann bist du quasi hier, na gut, achso, Cashback ist noch mal weniger, lul, S-Rock, die Mainboard
Preise sind richtig ordentlich, also das ist definitiv zu teuer, wir gucken mal kurz in
die Vergleichs, hat MSI nix, dass ich schon mal gleich weiß, welche ich rausnehmen kann,
weil eigentlich, eigentlich, wie gesagt, ich will von MSI nix kaufen, wer bräuchte so
Negativfilter, alles außer MSI, die Dinger sind mittlerweile so teuer, ok, jetzt vergleichen,
das Ding will ich schon mal nicht, das sieht so mega beschissen aus, das will ich nicht,
geh mal weg, äh, Ausvergleichslöschen, warum MSI, weil MSI mich ohne irgendwelche Gründe
gebannt hat vor Jahren auf Twitter, weil ich mich lustig gemacht hab über ihre RGB Beleuchtung,
habt ihr Pech, kauf ich nix von euch, wie wärs da mit einem Sonic Mainboard, oder gibts
bestimmt Leute, die stehen auf sowas, Sonic hat ja ganz weird Champige Fanbase teilweise,
die designen sich da, also fragt bitte nicht woher ich das weiß, aber ich weiß es, die
designen sich ja dann teilweise ihre eigenen Rule 34 Characters, da gibts teilweise ganz
merkwürdige Sachen, ich mein die machen auch normale Charakter, designen sie sich,
aber Sonic Fans sind teilweise etwas weird Champ, was haben wir denn hier, MSI, MSI kann
ich eigentlich auch gleich überspringen, Gigabyte Z97 Gaming X AX, also Gaming Sucks quasi,
das ist ein sehr unvorteilhafter Name, Sack,
das sieht doch gar nicht so verkehrt aus oder, hier war eigentlich ein Vorstellungsgespräch,
lief gut, das sieht doch gar nicht mal so verkehrt aus, Gigabyte Z97 Gaming X AX, warum findet
man da nix von denen, welchen O-Line Monitor wolltest du dir holen?
Das weiß ich noch nicht, das steht noch nicht fest, das Ding sieht gar nicht mal so verkehrt
aus, mal was anderes, mal kurz was anderes checken, ich lass das hier mal auf, wenn ich
Tosslink wegmach, dann sind wir schon bei 28, aber Leute ich will den optischen Audioausgang
haben, ansonsten müsste ich das irgendwie über die Grafikkarte dann zu Tosslink, weil
ich will das ja an mein Audiointerface anschließen und das geht am besten über den optischen
Audioausgang, deswegen ist mir fast die Soundkarte die auf dem Mainboard ist fast egal, das kommt
alles in mein Audiointerface dran und wenn du das per optischen Ausgang anschließt,
dann hast du überhaupt keine Probleme, dann ist vollkommen egal was du für eine Soundkarte
hast, das wird eh quasi digital übertragen ohne irgendwelche digital analog Wandlungsgeschichten
davor, zusätzliche Soundkarte, ja könnte man machen, also nee eigentlich will ich keine
zusätzliche Soundkarte, ja guck mal mal, also was haben wir denn hier zu bieten, was
war denn das hier, also das macht doch eigentlich keinen schlechten Eindruck, ich meine das
kostet 287 Euro, das nächste ist MSI, also die hier sind mir auf jeden Fall zu teuer,
also ich würde prinzipiell eigentlich nur bis 419, wären wir eigentlich schon zu viel
wenn ich ehrlich bin, was ist das denn Gigabyte Aero haben wir auch noch zu bieten, Aero G,
ok was ist der Unterschied zwischen denen, was ist zum Beispiel der Unterschied zwischen
dem da, nee zwischen dem da und dem da, schauen wir mal, kann man das verschieben vielleicht,
das wäre ganz praktisch, und das verschieben, exellent, also was ist da jetzt der Unterschied,
gerade alles exakt das gleiche, ah die unterschiedlich viele Anschlüsse, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
es reicht mir doch eigentlich was hier drauf ist, guck mal was ist, was haben wir hier für
Anschlüsse, also wir haben WiFi, wenn ich das richtig sehe, WiFi 6, gut brauche ich
nicht aber why not, wir haben für die GPU Ausgang, wir haben USB, USB C, optischen Ausgang
2,5 Gig, paar USBs, sieht doch vollkommen in Ordnung aus, so on Board haben wir einen
verstärkten PCI Express und zwei normale PCI Express, vollkommen ausreichend für mich,
hier kommen die Grafikkarte rein, und hier unten kommen die Capturekarte rein, falls
ich mir eine PCI Express Capturekarte kaufe, ansonsten habe ich ja da nichts, achso, Moment
die 10 Gig Karte, 10 Gig Karte kommt ja auch noch rein, fertig, PCI Express mal 4, auch
vollkommen ausreichend für die 10 Gig Karte, was für eine Grafikkarte ist angedacht, irgendeine
4090, ich weiß noch nicht genau welche, wahrscheinlich mache ich es davon abhängig was lieferbar
ist, wie war meine Bahn Experience in Würzburg, Leute ausgesprochen gut, es lief, es kam pünktlich
bei mir in Hanau der Zug an, der Zug kam pünktlich in Würzburg an, ist pünktlich
in Würzburg abgefahren und pünktlich in Hanau angekommen, also plus minus 5 Minuten, kannst
du dich echt nicht beschweren, vollkommen in Ordnung, wie wäre das zu wenig USB, naja
du hast ja auch nicht hinten alles am Rechner dran, sondern auch am Gehäuse und onboard
hast du ja bestimmt auch noch USB, guck hier hast du nochmal USB Header, ne hier hast du
nochmal USB Header für Front, das reicht dicke, das reicht dicke, guck mal, guck mal
du hast, für so Sachen wie Maus und Tastatur kannst du hier halt anschließen, das juckt
nicht, so und du hast, warum sind denn die, warum sind denn die rot und blau und die sind
nur blau und die sind rot und schwarz, ist das Quick Charge fähig oder was bedeuten
die Farben, guck mal du hast so wirklich mehr als genug USB Anschlüsse, du hast für Low
Performance Geräte wie Maus und Tastatur kannst du hier dran anschließen, habe ich
ein Case in Aussicht, ja, ein Fractal Design Meshify 2 XL, so dann hast du hier, superschnell
USB, superschnell, guck mal du hast 5 schnelle, normale klassische USB, was sind das, A Stecker
und das hier per USB C2, das ist doch absolut in Ordnung, kannst du dich nicht beschweren,
also hier, ich weiß genau wie ich das anschließen werde, also hier Maus, hier Tastatur, hier
unten kommt noch mein Mikro Eingang Interface dran, damit ich direkt aufnehmen kann, hier
kommt noch mein USB Mikro dran, für die Videos, hier kommt eine externe SSD wahrscheinlich
dran, das war's, mehr brauch ich nicht, genug, so alles passt, ganz ehrlich, warum sollte
ich mehr ausgeben als das für das Mainboard und ansonsten ist es auch, was ist das da
hinten eigentlich für ein fettes Ding, was ist das für ein super, ach ne da sind die
ganzen Anschlüsse drunter, jetzt erkenne ich das, ok, hier sind nochmal USB Front Anschlüsse,
und das hier ist wahrscheinlich der Gehäuseanschluss, eventuell, was ist das weiße Runde, meinst
du die Batterie, meinst du die Batterie, Moment Moment, hat das Ding keinen Power Knopf auf
dem Mainboard, doch, doch hat es, hier unten ist ein Power Knopf, also ich vermute mal das
ist ein Power Knopf oder, ne oder ist das ein Power Knopf, also Power Knopf auf dem Mainboard
finde ich persönlich immer sehr angenehm, was sind das für Knöpfe hier unten, Flash,
BIOS, Reset, Reset Knopf, wir gucken mal kurz ins Handbuch von diesem Ding, ich bin jetzt
ein bisschen planlos was das hier ist, also hier oben kommt anscheinend nochmal eine M2
SSD hin, und hier unten, ich dachte hier unten kommen die SSDs drunter, da müssen wir mal
kurz ins Handbuch gucken, ansonsten verstehe ich nicht warum ich mehr Geld ausgeben sollte
für ein Mainboard wenn ich ehrlich bin, also was ist jetzt wirklich der Vorteil, so ein
doppelt so teures Mainboard zu nehmen, ich meine Anschlüsse habe ich geguckt, alles
vollkommen in Ordnung, reicht mir dicke, mehr Anschlüsse brauche ich nicht, wir müssen
gucken ob die NVMe Anschlüsse hinhauen, das können wir gleich nochmal überprüfen, weil
als, Moment das machen wir jetzt, was brauchen wir für einen Anschluss für die SSD, das
braucht ein M-Key PCI-X4, hat das Ding, ja, vollkommen reicht, ist alles gut, Moin Unifying,
Displayport juckt mich nicht, nochmal zusätzlich USB 3.1, ist mir auch egal, Displayport,
Displayport in, Displayport in, wie jetzt, hat es da eingebaute Capture Card oder, Displayport
in, Displayport in ist für den Thunderbolt, ach so, also ist im Prinzip auch ein ganz
normaler Displayport plus Special Zeug, so ansonsten ist da jetzt nichts dabei was ich
unbedingt bräuchte, ok, das hat eine Intel-Onboard-Netzwerkkarte und das hat eine Realtek-Onboard-Netzwerkkarte,
interessiert mich aber eh nicht, weil ich meine 10G-Karte, also meine 10G-Netzwerkinterface
rein, Hänge, Headerkühlung, ok, da kann man natürlich jetzt mal gucken ob das von
der Steuerung, aber einmal CPU-4-Pin, einmal CPU-Lüfterpumpe 4-Pin, reicht, was, zweimal
Thermalsensor, einmal Noise-Sensor, was brauche ich da denn Sensor drinne, wie laut es ist,
ich meine ernsthaft, sehe ich das richtig, das hat quasi so eine Lautstärke, also ich
kann quasi mir anzeigen lassen wie laut mein Rechner ist, ist mir vollkommen egal ob
ich da Anzeige habe wie laut mein Rechner ist, wenn ich meinen Rechner nicht höre
im Desktopbetrieb ist alles gut, da brauche ich kein Sensor für, also wichtig ist, dass
wir nochmal extra Anschlüsse haben zum Regeln von der Wasserkühlung und der Rest ist doch
eigentlich Power-Button-Intern, ja wunderbar, wie gesagt die Soundkarte juckt mich eh nicht,
ich verwende eh den optischen Ausgang, Stromanschlüsse, einmal 24-Pin-ATX, zweimal 8-Pin, macht es
ein Unterschied, ok was mir das hier sagen soll, habe ich keinen Plan, PWM-Controller,
PWM-Controller für was, ich meine die Lüftersteuerung geht doch da drüber, die Lüftersteuerung geht
doch da drüber, also warum braucht man nochmal extra, das ist doch, also ich habe keine Ahnung,
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, was da der Unterschied ist, aber nein, ne die Wasserkühlung
kommt hier oben dran, an einen von den Lüftern, also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass man ohne
Probleme das günstige nehmen kann, also seht ihr beispielsweise an dem Mainboard irgendwas,
warum man das jetzt, seht ihr an diesem Mainboard was, was 140€ mehr wert ist, also ich für
meinen Fall jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, das einzige was ich nicht so ganz checke ehrlich
gesagt ist halt diese Geschichte hier, sieht cooler aus ok, was haben wir sonst noch zu
bieten, 302€ gibt es auch noch, aber MSI, ne ne ne, MSI, sorry MSI aber hier kommt
weg, dann hätten wir als nächstes nur noch und das kostet auch schon 60€ mehr, naja
50€, 50€ mehr, jetzt haben wir dreimal Gigabyte hintereinander, AORUS Elite AX, ok dann,
mal gucken, mal gucken ob da jetzt irgendwie ein Unterschied dazwischen ist, alles exakt
das gleiche, alles exakt das gleiche, das einzige was es hier dazu gibt ist noch nen
Vios Reset Button, ja schön und gut und dann gibt es hier Gedöns, es gibt eine RGB-Zone,
braun wir nicht, kein RGB, ob das wieviel RAM, äh nicht wieviel RAM, wieviel Speicher
das Vios hat geht mir sonst wo vorbei, was juckt mich das, überhaupt kein Ding, die
große Preisfrage ist doch eigentlich, ist es das hier, also ist es das hier wert, also
quasi diese Sachen hier mit diesem, was auch immer man mir das sagen soll an der Stelle,
ist das so viel besser als das hier, ich weiß es nicht, warum kein ASUS, weil die alle zu
teuer sind, ich overclocken da nichts, der wird ja schon, der wird schon ohne overclocken
abfuck heiß, guck mal das kostet mehr, das kostet mehr und hat keine RGB-Beleuchtung,
ok wisst ihr was, komm wir machen jetzt mal das da rein, wir machen das jetzt einfach,
ich will jetzt einfach wissen, was am Ende der Kram kostet und schliste, omega lul, so
jetzt fehlt bloß noch ne Grafikkarte, jetzt fehlt nur noch ne Grafikkarte und wir sind
schon, ok Grafikkarten 40,90, sortieren nach preis, manly, oh das ist nur für besonders
männliche Spieler, das ist nix für uns Leute, wir sind nicht alpha male genug für manly
Grafikkarten, Zotac, früher hatte ich recht viele Zotac Grafikkarten, oh die sieht tatsächlich
sogar mal, die sieht sogar ganz ok aus, Moment ist das wirklich echter Media Markt auf Ebay
oder ist das ein Ebay Shop der sich Media Markt nennt, Moment, ich rieche Tübayt, nee
das ist tatsächlich der echte Media Markt, warum verkauft Media Markt auf Ebay, warte
mal, dieser Artikel ist nicht vorrätig, Versand gratis Lieferung, ja wie jetzt, jetzt blick ich
nicht mehr durch, ist es jetzt lieferbar oder nicht, gratis Versand, nee ne, lagern Tübayt
von wegen lagern, von wegen lagern, ähm, Windforce, auch lagern, die sieht ja mal scheiße
aus, die sieht aus als hat der Lüfter nicht mehr richtig drauf gepasst, ok ganz ehrlich
so siehts gar nicht mehr so schlecht aus, aber von oben, also das sah wirklich, das
sah wirklich mies aus, letztendlich ist es wahrscheinlich vollkommen egal welche man
sich kauft, so das macht doch alles keinen großen Unterschied, ja Galaxus, gibt es vielleicht
auch irgendwelche Shops von denen ich schon mal was gehört hab, wo man sich, was kostet
aktuell bei Amazon 40.90, mach schall, achja Schnapper, kleid mir dazu, Galaxus hab ich
noch nie gehört, wirklich komplett neu, sag mal ist die fetter als die, Leute meint ihr
das täuscht, meint ihr das täuscht dass die so viel fetter ist wie die, das ist einfach
ne Frage des Bildes und des Winkels ist, ok lass mal kurz Abmaßen, Abmaße gucken, Abmessung
versus, ne die ist sogar noch größer, die ist sogar größer als die fette, ne die ist
noch mal größer, guck mal, die andere ist nur 329mm lang und 71mm hoch, also die sind
beide gleich hoch und die sind beide, aber die hier ist noch breiter und noch länger
als die hier, das ist ja 3,5 Slots, auch 3,5 Slots, ja steht ja da, was für fette Dinge
man, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern die erste Grafikkarte die ich hatte, die 2 Slots,
3,5 Slots, was ist denn mit euch los man, geht das mit dem Mainboard oder mit dem Gehäuse,
gut ja gehts, gehts aber, was ist denn mit euch verkehrt man, 3,5 Slots, gutes im Gehäuse
dürfte es kein Problem geben, gut der Mainboard ist, Leute ich bin mir gar nicht mal so sicher
ob das gescheit funktioniert, meint ihr das act vielleicht an, hier, ob das anact an diesem
komischen Ding, ach das geht ja nach unten, ihr habt ja recht das geht nach unten, ne
das, deswegen ist hier so ein, das geht nach unten, ja ja ok, da habt ihr recht, das ist
ok, dann geht das, Game Rock, der Unterschied zwischen den ganzen Grafikkarten ist doch relativ
marginal oder, die eine kommt vielleicht mit ein bisschen mehr Takt standardmäßig als
die andere, ich hau das Teil jetzt einfach mal rein, dass ich mal so ungefähr ne Gesamthausnummer
hab, ach Garantie das Ding geht eh nicht kaputt, wenns kaputt geht, ist eh abfuck, Copium, so
erster Gesamthausnummer, da geht schon was, Leute das wird nicht billig, muss nur gucken
dass die dir nicht die PCI Slots überragt, ich denke mal, ich denke mal das müsste passen,
das steht doch bestimmt, das steht doch hier bestimmt irgendwie drin oder, oder im Handbuch
oder sowas, warum Intel nicht AMD, weil Intel Gaming Performance Technik aktuell ein bisschen
besser ist, sonst hat das keinen tieferen Grund, lass mal kurz gucken, haben die irgendwie
das Handbuch von dem Ding, ein Dokument, die Bedienungsanleitung genau die brauch ich,
ja Leute ich mach demnächst wieder ein bisschen Genshin Werbung, dann ist das easy wieder
drinne, ne ich hab Inflationsausgleich bekommen, fast 3000 Euro diesen Monat, plus 14es Monatsgehalt,
easy Money, easy Live, gibt zwar einen neuen Rechner, kommt PC Build Stream, Moment DDR4,
ne das ist für alles, 14es Monatsgehalt ja, ok das ist für die M2, was, M2 CPU, M2 SB,
was sollen wir diese komischen Begriffe jetzt genau sagen, hast du, was hast du echt bekommen,
was, ja, Inflationsausgleich und 14es Monatsgehalt, 14es Monatsgehalt gibts immer bei uns im Dezember
und es gab jetzt noch ein bisschen Inflationsausgleich, kann ich mich nicht beschweren, zumindest
nicht für den Dezember, der obere PC läuft über die CPU, hä, es laufen alle PCI express
über die CPU, oder nicht, ach so, wie, das geht nicht mehr alles über die CPU, sowas
wie Chipset und so gibt es noch seit Jahren nicht mehr, oder gibt es das wieder, haben
wir das wieder jetzt eingeführt, oder, weil die CPU nicht genug Lanes hat, ahja, muss
man das im Vertrag ausmachen, ja klar, das muss schon, ich mein, dein Arbeitgeber ist
ja natürlich frei, den es auch so zu überweisen, aber ja, das muss schon irgendwo vereinbart
sein, also sollte ich meine SSD dann da oben anschließen, hat die dann noch mehr Performance
oder was, oder wo, also wenn ich hier oben meine NVMe SSD anschließe, ist noch besser,
ok, ja soll mir recht sein, ich mein, passt schon, aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch nur
in der Theorie, wahrscheinlich macht es praktisch gesehen, 1MB die Sekunde aus, thermisch besser,
naja, ich hab ja da keine Luftkühlung drauf, hier unten kommt ja dann eh nur noch meine
10G Karte rein, und vielleicht ne Capture Card, eh nachdem, ne, das ist so ne PCIe 4 NVMe,
Leute, 3,5, wait a minute, 3,5 Slots braucht das, 1 Slot, so, übern Daumen gepeilt, ja,
Leute, übern Daumen gepeilt, 1 Slot, 2 Slot, 3 Slot, also quasi hier ist die GPU dann fertig,
so weit in der Theorie, oder, so ungefähr hier müsste die GPU aufhören, sodass ich
hier meine Capture Karten, hier meinen WC Karten rein machen kann, ja, das müsste passen,
so dann haben wir ein, wo ist denn der Power Knopf, wo ist der Power Knopf auf dem Mainboard,
das hier ist Reset, Bios Clear hat das kein Power Knopf, laut Geizhals hat das nen Power
Knopf, warum so ne fette GPU, weil ich die haben will, ich will das haben, das ist generell
das hauptsächliche bei dem Rechner, weil ich den haben will, ja, Mainboard, eh, Mainboard
Bücher immer noch ziemlich pepega, Button, Onboard Buttons, zeig mal her, quickly, Moment,
der Reset Button ist der An-Aus Schalter, warum alles in der Welt nennt man den Reset Button
und nicht Power On, Power Off, SW oder so, oder Power SW, warum heißt der Reset, Reset
ist bei mir Reset und nicht Power On, Power Off, was auch immer, nicht China-Chinesen
Hersteller hinterfragen, wobei, nee, Gigabyte ist gar kein China-Chinesen Hersteller, das
ist nicht der Power Button, natürlich ist es der Power Button, nein, want to change Hardware
Components, quickly turn on off, das ist kein Reset Button, das ist ein Power Button, der
Reset Button heißt, ok, Reset Button provides several functions, remap the button to perform
the, ok, man kann das auch noch umstellen, RST Multi Key, Leelu Multi Pass, Multi Key,
das ist aber schon wieder, Massive, Massive kompliziert gemacht, oder, ja, Multi Key,
also was kann man machen, use button to reset the system, use button to turn on off LEDs,
use the button to enter BIOS Setup, use the button to boot system in Safe Mode, alles klar,
Jumper, noch mal, DIP Switch, Jumper ist, kennt ihr noch diese DIP Switches, diese ganz
kleinen Furzdinger mit diesen Hoch-Runter-Klipse-Schaltern, ok, was haben wir noch für einen Button, Clear
BIOS Configuration, ok, nice, Flash Plus Button, Status LEDs, ja, wunderbar, Internal Connectors,
ja, nee, passt doch, was mich echt irritiert hat ist Media Markt auf Ebay, hätte ich jetzt
nicht gedacht, dass Media Markt auf Ebay am Start ist, aber gut.
Wo ist die Grafikkarte, guck mal, es ist exakt das gleiche, Boost 2520, Boost, oh, oh, nein,
Leute, 15 Megahertz mehr Boost, OMG, das ist aber bestimmt der Killer schlechthin, 15
Megahertz mehr GPU-Takt, Leute, 15 Megahertz, da müssen wir bestimmt, da sollten wir schon
mal 300 Euro mehr für ausgeben, ich glaube, das passt soweit, ich glaube, das ist ganz
gut, ganz gute Config hier, Festplatte habe ich noch, 10T, brauche ich nicht, jetzt benötige
ich noch ein paar Noctua Gehäuse-Lüfter, aber die brauche ich nicht, weil das Gehäuse
bringt ja welche mit, ich glaube, das kann ich mir mehr oder weniger so bestellen und
das Gute ist, ah, das ist nicht lieferbar, ok, da muss ich was andrücken und das Gute
ist, es ist alles irgendwo lieferbar, ich würde sagen, da wird es Zeit mal zu bestellen,
habe ich noch irgendwas vergessen, also ich habe zum Beispiel gelesen, dass es noch die
Möglichkeit gibt, das habe ich glaube ich beim Bauer auf dem YouTube-Channel gesehen,
dass es noch die Möglichkeit gibt, so einen extra Rahmen für die Wasserkühlung auf die
CPU zu machen oder, nee, besser gesagt, dass man den Rahmen auf dem Mainboard irgendwie
tauscht zu einem eigenen Rahmen, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, was der Sinn davon ist und ich
glaube auch nicht, dass ich das machen würde, mein, wozu, ist da Wärmeleitpaste dabei?
Was ist das hier, Montage-Kit, was, Montage-Kit für Sockel noch möglicherweise noch nicht
im Lieferumfang, was, wie, ist dabei, ich soll sieben Tage darauf warten, bis ihr mir so,
Alter, warum ist da nichts dabei, wollt ihr mich veräbeln, was ist denn das, laut Aussender
des Herstellers kann bei Produkten der Serie Liquid Freezer 2 ein Mangel am Dichtungsmaterial
bei Übergang, wie, wenn ich mir das kaufe, habe ich Pech und bekomme vielleicht eins
mit einer kaputten Dichtung, ich sehe schon kommen, ich kann meinen Rechner nicht zusammenbauen,
weil ich erst ein Umrüst-Kit mir schicken lassen muss und dann noch die Dichtung austauschen
muss, Keklmann, das ist ja, das ist ja nix, das ist ja Müll, die Rahmen sind für, ja,
also ich hab, ich hab sowas beim Bauer auf YouTube gesehen, das nannte sich irgendwie,
wie heißt diese Bauer, Bauer Marke nochmal, Thermal Grizzly glaube ich, ja, und dann irgendwie
genau Contact Frame, sowas, sowas in der Richtung, ich glaube nicht, dass sich das
bei mir lohnt, oder, da muss man das Mainboard modifizieren, soweit ich gesehen hab und ich
weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt, auf der anderen Seite Garantie von Mainboard ist mir eh egal
und 39 Euro kann man sich eigentlich das auch, man, jede Temperatur, die man spart, ist gut,
ne, ne, ne, direkte Kühlung auf der CPU mach ich nicht, ich werd meine CPU nicht mehr
aufmachen, das hab ich beim 8700K gemacht, die CPU geköpft, das mach ich nicht mehr,
vor allem es bringt auch jetzt weniger als damals, hat jemand sowas, hat jemand sowas
im Einsatz und, ok, wir gucken da einfach mal danach, Review, was das wirklich bringt,
Tom's Hardware, die gibt's hier immer noch, das ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche, kopiert
vom anderen Hersteller, oder, du du du du du du du du du.
Gamer Nexus, ok, weil ihr's seid, Gamer Nexus.
Ich, ich, ich spule aber ein bisschen vor.
This piece of metal is $4.35 right now on AliExpress and we are going to trust it to
bend our
die China Chinesen
our $800 Intel i9-12900KS.
This is the highly requested for review Thermalright LGA1700 contact frame or as Thermalright
calls it, it is the CPU bending correction frame protector fixing buckle
was bedeutet das etwa dass die CPU sich normalerweise biegt oder wie das kann ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen die bauen doch keine CPUs die sich im Mainboard biegen ok doch das kann
durchaus sein dass sie sich nicht wirklich großartig biegen sondern quasi so im weniger
als millimeter bereich und dadurch die kühlung eben nicht so gut ist wie sie sein könnte
das ist gut genug wir werden es auf unseren 12900KS vertrauen also kommt es direkt mit der
$35 ThermalGrizzly Kontakt Fram, die wir vorhin gesehen haben, und nachdem die Preisdifferenzen
wir erwarten zumindest etwas anders zu sein, aber für 4,5 Euro fast die Thermalright Fram
ist in starker Konkurrenz mit dem was ThermalGrizzly angefangen hat.
Bevor das, dieses Video wurde von Squarespace brought to you, wie baut man sowas denn drauf,
das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Und für 7°C ist das ein großer Lauf, besonders wenn man etwas wie eine kleine Formfaktor-Solution
sieht.
Das ist eigentlich meistens leer, es sieht so aus, dass es viel mehr Paste hat als es
wirklich macht, weil die Plunder fast alle Wege runter, man bekommt vielleicht ein Gramm
oder ein bisschen mehr hier, und es kommt mit einem Torx-Drucker, den man an die Schrauben
anstrengen muss.
Die Thermalright Fram-Kolore sind schön und sie sehen gut aus, wenn man sie wieder zurück
zu dem anstrengen.
In der Theorie, diese sehr...
Nee, da ist es ja schon drauf, man sieht gar nicht wie er das montiert, oder?
Er ist es schon montiert.
Nee, da ist es überall schon installiert, man sieht nicht, wie das installiert wird.
Oh, das ist schon...
Das ist schon drauf.
Ah ja, ok, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier kriegt man es jetzt gezeigt.
Hier kriegt man es jetzt gezeigt.
Wir werden es heute nicht wieder übernehmen, aber wir haben ein paar Animationen gemacht,
die zeigen, wie das Intel ILI oder das independent Loading Mechanism funktioniert,
und wie es Druck verwendet, und wo es Schwierigkeiten hat,
die beide dieser Kontakt-Frame komponiert lösen können,
ob sie von einem viel cheaperen oder mehr teureren Brand sind.
Zuerst in unserem Test ist das Druck-Test.
Wir benutzen ein chemisch-reaktives Kabel.
Ich will mal sehen, wie man das montiert. Wie montiert man das?
Hast du Urlaub? Ja, bis 3. Januar.
Hier, hier zeigt das, hier zeigt das, wie das geht.
Ja, und an den Seiten.
Ja gut, es drückt halt an den Seiten auf die CPU runter.
Die Kabel haben schon nichts.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Aha, okay, okay. Jetzt habe ich das Problem halbwegs verstanden.
Ja, ich habe fast kein Urlaub des Jahres.
Aber ich mache dann immer kompletten Dezember, trage ich Urlaub ein.
Okay, jetzt habe ich das Problem kapiert.
Ich würde mich interessieren, wie man das montiert.
Aha.
Nee.
Ach, jetzt zeigen sie es, jetzt zeigen sie es, okay.
Okay.
Das hat er eigentlich ganz gut ausgesprochen, muss man sagen.
Das ist alles?
Ah, nee, da kommt noch was.
Das ist ja easy.
Das ist ja wirklich.
Das habe ich ja dann quasi auch.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ziemlich easy, oder?
Da kann man nicht wirklich was großartig verkehrt machen.
Aber wie kriegt man denn da jetzt die Wasserkühlung dann drauf fest?
Man hat jetzt ja gar keine Löcher mehr.
Okay.
Gibt es dafür nicht so passende Ratschen oder so, wo man das einstellen kann?
Wobei das wahrscheinlich so geringer Anzieh, wie nennt man das?
Anzieh, Druck, keine Ahnung, wie man es trägt.
Drehmoment heißt es auf Deutsch.
Wahrscheinlich hat man sowas gar nicht daheim.
Wobei ist das jetzt der Thermal?
Ach nee, das ist der Thermal Grizzly.
Das andere ist der Thermal Take.
Was?
Jetzt wird es aber high IQ langsam.
Ach, deswegen haben die da Striche drauf gemacht.
Okay, das kriege ich hin.
Das scheint nicht so kompliziert zu sein.
Zeigen Sie das hier für den Thermal?
Ja.
Hier wird das andere Ding montiert.
Ach, hier kriegen wir jetzt gezeigt, wie der andere montiert wird.
Ah, das klickt.
Ah, die haben da was eingebaut, dass man es nicht zu fest anziehen kann.
Ach, er dreht rückwärts.
Hä, warum dreht er rückwärts?
Okay, das ist zu high IQ für mich.
Ach, das ist, dass er immer am gleichen Punkt anfängt zu schrauben.
Ah, ja, ja, ja, okay.
Ganz ehrlich, die Montage von dem billig Ding erscheint mir sogar einfacher zu sein.
Okay, also ich werde durch alle vier Körner gehen und diese langsam durchlaufen.
Und der Grund, warum ich das in Segmenten mache, oder in 90-Grad-Inkrementen, ist,
dass es die Fram von Off-Kilter oder durchlaufen, unabhängig nach unten,
in Richtung der CPU, anziehen wird.
Okay, also ich lege die CPU langsam.
Wenn du nicht aufpasst, machst du deine CPU kaputt im Zweifelsfall oder verbiegst dir irgendwas.
Ich glaube, ich hole mir auch so ein Ding.
Ich habe Bock, das auch einzubauen.
Ich meine, wo hat man sonst mal die Chance, eine 700-Euro-CPU und ein 350-Euro-Mainboard zu zerstören,
das man selbst bezahlen muss?
Ist das jetzt ein Muss? Nein, das ist kein Muss.
Das geht auch alles komplett ohne.
Du kriegst es bloß vielleicht, wenn du Glück hast, ein paar Grad kühler.
Das so ein Ding kaufe ich mir auch.
Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt nicht noch mal erklären lassen.
Irgendwann ist es ja auch mal gut, mit vier Schrauben anzuziehen.
Das kriege ich schon gebacken.
So, wie heißt dieses Ding?
Thermal-Ride.
Contact.
Nee.
Nee, Contact, nicht Contract.
So ein Teil hier.
Sollte mit einem Bosch Akkuschrauber auch machbar sein.
Nein, das zieht dir doch viel zu stark das Ding an.
Du hast an dem Akkuschrauber zwar auch eine Einstellung, aber nicht so weit runter.
Also ich glaube, das Kleinste, was bei meinem geht...
Ich glaube, das Kleinste, was bei meinem geht, sind zehn.
Irgendwie so was, das reicht ja im Leben, das dreht sich das Mainboard durch.
Ist ja auch gar nicht lieferbar.
Oder doch, hier.
Ist auch gar nicht lieferbar.
Ja, dann muss ich mir das Ding vom Bauer holen.
Guru bei Guru, alles klar.
Was kostet das Ding?
Was ist denn das Lapping Tool?
Leute, das ist ja wieder ein Fass ohne Boden.
Was?
Das ist ein Tuch?
Nee.
Lapping Tool.
Was bin ich sehend?
Was ist das?
Beeinfacht das Schleifen der CPU?
Nee, nee, nee.
Ist gut.
Man will es nicht übertreifen.
reifen heißt wie heißt dieses ding noch mal den ich sammel take sammel right war das oder
right tpu bending correction mounting buckle okay das ist das richtige aber das ist doch
auch nur aus china lieferbar oder wenn ich mir das hier so angucke nur wobei geht doch eigentlich
ja wunderbar okay leute das das fällt jetzt wirklich nicht großartig ins gewicht ich haue
mal kurz dieses ding hier rein einfach nur dass es drinne steht das werde ich mir woanders bestellen
wärmeleitpasta habe ich noch ich habe noch vom der bauer ich hatte mir zwei stücke kauft damals
verletzten rechner einmal so eine flüssig metalligierung normale wärmeleitpasta und die
kann ich kann ich wieder verwenden cryonaut genau kondaktornaut und kreokreokreonaut oder so sehr
nice lasst uns mal gerade noch mal bei grafikkarten gucken gerade mal bei grafikkarten gucken ob es
noch irgendwas anderes lieferbares gibt manly lieferbar okay kurzfristig ist auch in ordnung
oder gigabyte die habe ich ja die habe ich ja gerade reingepackt die ist überhaupt nicht
lieferbar jetzt ist es galaxus oder wie ganz ehrlich ich nehme die wärmeleitpasta die bei
der wasserkühlung dabei ist das macht eh kein unterschied wir haben doch eigentlich was ganz
gutes rausgesucht finde ich finde ich gut finde ich nice finde ich nice was ich nicht so nice
finde ist was es dann kostet am ende also aktuell sind wir bei 4622 euro cringe unter 5000 ja ich
weiß hyper cringe leute richtig richtig hart harter cringe wenn ich vergeblich 5000 euro
von rechner aus aber es ist auch komplett rgb los mit rgb kann man das wahrscheinlich ohne probleme
auf über 5000 kriegen so jetzt ist eure möglichkeit was würdet ihr noch ändern beziehungsweise habt
ihr irgendwas gesehen was ihr sagen würde das würde ich auf keinen fall so machen also wie
gesagt ram ist noch nicht ganz klar irgendwas was lieferbar ist aber ansonsten sieht das doch
eigentlich echt ganz brauchbar aus netzteil bin ich mir auch noch nicht ganz sicher eine zweite
ssd brauche ich nicht zweite ssd habe ich ja schon netzteil ist ausreichend ja das reicht also ich
werde ja vom alten pc die festplatte mitnehmen und ich werde vom alten pc die usb ssd mitnehmen
das heißt da ist da ist auch alles mögliche drauf was ich so brauche und wo ich noch videos
drauf aufnehme und sowas und ich brauche keine zweite interne ssd auf der anderen seite bei
dem preis könnte man es fast schon machen ja sli gibt es nicht mehr du würdest einen guten
luftkühler nehmen auf keinen fall wenn ich luftkühler nehme bräuchte ich auch nicht das fette
gehäuse könnte ganz andere könne ich ganz anders da aufbauen temperatur technisch ist die
wasserkühlung einfach deutlich besser und im desktop betrieb hörst du da auch nicht viel
der ganze ziel du kannst ja quasi auch regeln über die lüfteranschlüsse vom mainboard
wofür usb ssd dass man sie abziehen kann an den rechner machen kann ich brauche keine
noctua lüfter also erstens habe ich noch 120 mm 80 80 und 120 mm noctua lüfter in
meinem server gehäuse aber auf der anderen seite das gehäuse kommt mit drei lüfter die
sind durchaus in ordnung und die wasserkühlung hat hat eigene lüfter selbst hat eigentlich
die grafika hat eigentlich ich brauche keine zuletzt lüfter mehr kompatibilitätsliste des
mainboards ja guck mal was sie was der für einen ram hat ja maximal beziehung locker easy kein
problem geht ohne probleme drauf oder meinst du explizit nach diesem ram ne das das muss
funktionen erwarte ich dass das funktioniert hier hast du 42 90 moment das gibt es ernsthaft
dachte es gibt kein sli mehr warum haben die da 42 90 drin wo ist wo ist der sinn
die zweite zum capture wir machen die dass ich wie gesagt ich dachte eigentlich sowas
wie sli gibt es nicht mehr aber ganz im ernst bin juckt ist ja nicht so als wäre 41 90 jetzt
zu wenig performance was der ganze spaß kostet das willst du nicht wissen ist nicht ganz billig
aber das schöne ist dass alles lieferbar ist also wie gesagt ram werde ich noch mal gucken
mainboard bin ich mir auch noch nicht hundertprozentig sicher ob es das so wird günstigster anbieter
für alle produkte ermitteln ok ja und jetzt da mache ich mal das ram kurz raus wenn es
sonst rumbug und jetzt was bringt mir das jetzt dass ich das hier eingestellt habe ach so
das ist dass ich dass ich beispielsweise alles alles bei alternate oder so bestellen könnte
ne das wird wahrscheinlich nix das muss ich schon bei unterschiedlichen leden bestellen
was ist mein budget na ja sagen wir so 5000 euro reicht mir mehr muss nicht sein komme
ich eigentlich ganz gut mit hin jetzt aber das ist lieferbar unter anderem bei was ist
baracks equipa hierbei kompatibilitätsliste ok zeige ja g skill obviously das da alles
klar 6400 aber jetzt schon das bin ich relativ sicher dass das passt ich würde den kram
eh nach möglichkeit ok das ist tatsächlich ziemlich ziemlich wild aufgeteilt über alle
möglichen shops was willst du machen das willst du machen das gefällt mir doch das
setup das setup hat was ich glaube da werde ich mich jetzt mal ans bestellen wagen entweder
heute noch oder oder diese woche irgendwann noch wird wird zeit übrigens für dreizehnte
generation cpus kann man das sicherlich auch verwenden ich mal in java script schreibt
man klassen vorne groß und funktion klein oder fragst mich was glaub schon guck mal
die suchen mich leute die suchen mich vielleicht sollte ich vielleicht sollte ich einfach zu
geizhals gehen zeig mal ich bin blind ich sehe nix mehr was soll man denn hier können
verpflichtende kenntnisse erfahrungen der professionellen administration und gestaltung
von art infrastrukturen netzwerken ok linux alles klar shell scripting ja alles klar vermögen
was muss ich regelmäßig einkaufen damit das funktioniert oder ach so das vermögen
sich in kurzer zeit neue technologie erfahrungen mit modernen rechenzentren gänge hardware
erfahrungen postgres redis zabbix ansible krafanox-kibana varnish habe ich keine ahnung
was varnish ist cash für dynamische webseiten mit vielen geht es habe ich noch nie gehört
kenne ich nicht varnish das jemand die anderen sagen mir was aber das habe ich noch nicht
gehört varnish high performance htp accelerator excellent da habe ich drauf gewartet nix apache
in mail virtualisierungsrichtungen mit woosa skills alles klar das ist das ist nicht tisch
tennis sondern kicker zeug oder tisch kicker das mindestgrundgehalt für diese position
beträgt 3600 ist jetzt aber netzhote wahnsinn geizhalser da ist der name pro gramme die
sind nicht nur bei den angeboten geizhals sondern auch bei monatsgehalt der name ist
pro gramme kannst du nicht sagen das ist aber nicht viel weil das sind 33 38 38,5 8 8 stunden
am tag also sind 7,25 oder so oder 7,52 stunden am tag das ist wirklich nicht die welt
da ja
das war jetzt nochmal der unterschied aber da gibt es auch kein 150 euro mehr für nice
ok leute wahrscheinlich bauen wir dann nächste woche ne wobei bis nächste woche ist das nicht
alles da ich muss gucken wo ich es bestelle also ich würde ungern tatsächlich jedes teil
bei einem anderen shop bestellen ich ja bestell das nach möglichkeit so auf zwei drei shops
aufgeteilt weil man hat nicht überall die sachen bekommt und man könnte beispielsweise
mal gucken was man davon bei alternate oder so kriegt was es wird kann ich dir zeigen
ja gesamtpreis stimmt nicht ganz weil ich den ram grad rausgelöscht habe es wird ob
es die grafikkarte exakt wird weiß ich auch noch nicht es wird 40 90 auf jeden fall die
cpu das mainboard das gehäuse die wasserkühlung und wahrscheinlich das netzteil aber da muss
ich auch noch mal genau gucken aber das kommt jetzt 90 prozent sowas in der richtung wird
und entweder bestelle ich heute bestelle ich es noch nicht das ist mir zu kurz wie ich
bestell das morgen ich lasse mir das noch mal durch den kopf gehen guck mir noch mal
die einzelnen sachen an so nach dass es nach möglichkeiten irgendwie bei zwei drei shops
bestellt werden kann und dann geht es ab nächste woche wird gebildet frexor dankeschön für
den sub dankeschön leute für die ganzen subscriptions heute ich habe die hälfte nicht gesehen weil
ich zu vertieft war in meinen pc bild also viel habe ich gar nicht übersehen der möb
hat noch subscrib dankeschön und auch für die ganzen follows nvidia spinn ja aber ich
bezahle es trotzdem wird mal wieder zeit für nvidia sponsoring würde ich sagen verwendest
du noch alte hardware komponenten ja ich verwende die festplatte und die externe ssd noch ansonsten
nix kommando an die dankeschön für den sub sonst nix sonst kommt alles neue hast du was
am black friday er gatt hat nö gab es jetzt nichts was mich groß gejuckt hätte alles klar
leute ich hau mal ab wir sehen uns bis dann macht's gut zu